in his speech last night the president
also underlined his plan to remove u.s
troops from afghanistan after nearly 20
years in that country the final pullout
is scheduled to begin next month this
morning charlie dagetta is in
afghanistan for us for a close-up look
at some of the afghan forces who will be
expected to continue the fight
against the taliban with the taliban
gaining more
ground by the day traveling by road has
never been more dangerous
so we were flown to the military base
where afghan soldiers were putting on a
show of force
staged military exercises the weapons
and training provided
by american troops the taliban has
already threatened to escalate attacks
once the us misses the previously agreed
may first deadline to withdraw
and the u.s military is preparing for
that sending in hundreds of army rangers
b-52 bombers and the uss
eisenhower to safeguard the full-on but
by 9 11
all u.s troops will be gone it will be
down to hundreds of thousands of
afghan service members to defend against
the taliban
especially these u.s train commandos
with women such as
maroufa a special forces soldier taking
a central role many say if the taliban
take over control they're going to take
away
women's rights what is your message to
the taliban
it is not possible the taliban came and
control our government
and what if they try if they try we will
fight with them
one of the reasons for the u.s
withdrawal is the belief that
afghanistan will no longer be a launch
pad for terrorist attacks by groups
like al qaeda but commanders on the
ground here tell us
al qaeda and the taliban are
intrinsically linked
in his words they're like family what
else
then general yasin zia and his forces
now
face the prospect of a taliban offensive
without the backup
of u.s military support and air power
what will you miss most about the u.s
presence here
the friendship the friendship yeah
because
we we fought together for 20 years and
we we must fight there is no
other option as long as the taliban are
fighting
against us and they it looks like they
will then we don't have any other option
the general told us american troops have
already started pulling back from bases
in the south and the east that's where
the taliban are at their strongest
as for whether afghan forces will be
ready to hold their own
the top american general here says
they'll have to be
gail right charlie dagetta reporting
from kabul thank you